bringing Jared Dudley Phoenix Suns
forward Jared joins me here on the show
which is the better team Jared Houston
or Golden State home state Constance's
you know today our is the other 10 meter
per degree I think Houston has played
better throughout the year but it's just
something when those four all-stars get
together when they're motivated when
when the playoffs want to play offset
and they know what the task at hand I
think that was held orleans series they
could take it to a whole nother notch
and i expect even though I'm rooting for
Houston and actually going to Game one I
expect the series is over the Warriors
to show that they even have another
level and that that Houston will feel
basically push them to the brink okay
but what you're saying when you say
championship pedigree why does that
matter in a series like this does that
matter because Chris Paul's making his
debut in the Conference Finals that
James Harden's never won a title why
does that matter in a series like this I
think that you saw some whatnot almighty
Bishop had agreed you just saw an
affiliate Boston series I mean silly oh
you could tell those their first playoff
series and I think that it's a different
eye when we played the Lakers when I was
listening with Nash in those days ago we
had Steve Nash no more instead of are
you could see the championship pedigree
Kobe and the Lakers have when it comes
to these finals it's it's the world
players it's someone like Shawn litmus
and Ingrid ala compared to now Eric
Gordon Ryan Anderson PJ Tucker types
where these guys have been in there they
know the exact roles the shots they shot
before that you know a knowledge of
available Finals MVP is the role guys
that have been there before
now David West or this is what they've
been you know this is what they've been
going all season for they've been here
many times and I think that's gonna show
I think that James Harden will be
brilliant Kevin Durant will be brilliant
and the question is can harden have four
brilliant games that's why it's so hard
to beat LeBron because LeBlanc
give you that in the series to build a
win at a seven-game so that that's
really gonna be the key connait is he
gonna be unstoppable for those hopefully
six or seven games for them okay devil's
advocate because I don't disagree with
you I think it's I until somebody beats
Golden State in the Western Conference
pour out a set
I'm gonna have to wait and see to
predict against them getting beaten four
to seven but you said that Golden State
took their games to another level
against the pelicans and I agree with
that too but I also saw the Rockets
elevate themselves after losing Game two
they adjusted and they beat down the
Jazz was that not equally as impressive
to you not equally just because a Jazz
when I have full strength
I thought Ricky will be able to play a
different role in that series I still
think that Houston would have won I just
at the way New Orleans morass Portland
and their small blow on Anthony Davis
and Mirotic because he there's only
there's only a couple teams with Houston
is runnable the versatility they have
this foot starting lineups you see Brad
Caesar does it based on the starting
lineup Steve Kerr does a lot of coaches
are afraid of that Kerr is not you know
England a low coming in at and then
putting him on Mirotic and it's just a
versatility where you know can Houston
D'Antoni is known to do that
noplease a Tucker's play some backup
five you're basically saying hey we're
playing your style of ball and we're
trying to beat you your style and I just
think that with the firepower they have
of staff clay and Katie to a seven-game
series I think their versatility on
offense not just to be one-dimensional
or in the playing out throughout this
series Jared Dudley Phoenix Suns for
joining me here on the Dan Patrick show
do you think this the Rockets can play
enough defense to win this series for
sure that's the one thing that I don't
think the people get enough credit they
can't I just think that one thing's
gonna out score so when it comes down to
I think they're both going to be good I
think even Game one I could see even was
it called I said Golden State struggling
in Game one the one thing that Houston
does better than any other team is which
every every ball screen not only did I
switch ball screens they'll switch pin
downs so some of my klay Thompson when
you moved you know these pin Del's and
jump shots the Rockets are gonna take
that away clay is not gonna have on
these 19-point quarters because they
switch it and all the defenders besides
James Harden their starting five or
above average defenders I mean I mean V
plus to a minus PJ Tucker can tell
Chris Paul and obviously trevor ariza
moot a comes in otherwise
so defensively is not going to be their
problem the problem is when they switch
Ollie screams Kevin Durant is gonna have
the mismatch to most likely every single
time which he usually does anyway we're
having Chris Paul harden on him when
they do these screens it's gonna open
them up a lot all right let me ask you
about the Eastern Conference two teams
that on some level are in the Conference
Finals somewhat improbably I mean I
guess LeBron being there isn't bad and
probables has done it eight consecutive
seasons but you know they've had their
issues this year
Boston's injury issues which team are
you more surprised is in the Conference
Finals right now Boston Boston by a
little bit I think that we don't give
enough credit to all these players a lot
of it we give a credit Brad Stevens and
rightfully so but Tatum's stud Jalen
brownells said last year towards the end
and we knew that he doesn't have a big
season his potential their versatility
we didn't know about Rozier we didn't
know Wells ear was this good and grass
even is a lot of that credit he's good
defensively he takes big shots he makes
big shots how Harper's their key key the
reason why their offense is so so unique
he'll remove it is because they have a
five whose IQ long the best in the NBA
he could shoot the three he makes all
the right decisions complain small ball
he can punish you in the post so I would
put them and when it comes to Cleveland
what the thing is can you be LeBron four
out of seven he finds a way the game
slows down the ball in his hand more now
that has ever been his whole career and
that's why I think that Boston will give
him trouble because the bosses don't
throw a lot of bodies at him to wear
head down and I just think that he'll
have one game where he's gonna win in
Boston and can Boston from a mental edge
being as a young team deal with that
because they've never never lose at home
LeBron is gonna find a way to win one
game in Boston that always happens every
time he plays he's gonna have one of
those games camera loves a couple of
these threes and can they build a good
enough wins on the road and be able to
win in Cleveland to win this series I
don't think they can
why was Indiana more effective against
Cleveland and Toronto was Indiana go
thought the whole season has been the
scrappiest
dirtiest I mean 30 in a good way team
physical and you hate the ones who will
get you hate to play okay if you didn't
play hard enough they're gonna win by 20
and so the one of the problems with well
more problems with the Cavaliers is they
don't play hard all the time they're bad
in transition defense
besides you know before they were
playing Tristan Thompson they don't have
any physical players you know love is
pretty physical downloads a certain
degree
so their athleticism daddy is young to
be his versatile being defended to a
guard LeBron and Kevin Love it's a
different matchup where Toronto I think
we all agree their mental as Cleveland
has but I don't think they had that
player like Vic going people were hey
Noah can Garvey you can't trap me I'm
not looking for fouls
I'm just more socks or athletic and
Channing Tatum can't be that player is
he great at this age to be able to do it
and that's what that's what waiting for
here come here come on Sunday
you played with both Mars mother
brothers in Phoenix ever have any
problems telling them apart never
Markieff Markieff had lots of your
cheeks you could never tell you wears
and stuff like that he's a little bit
more Marcus is a little more leaner and
how about that story you know these are
two guys that you think that overall you
know they can really only got a bad rep
I remember talking to Ames for a game a
love them and at what he's done 14 being
a starter in Detroit and last people
don't buy in now he was a starter do a
lot of contract here coming up nuts here
and coming off the bench and you know
get the same rest you got a credit
you've never hear anything bad about
about Boston those players
sacrificing and you only see me the next
year when these two stars come back and
also credit to the question staff you
remember there was a long time people
thought that they couldn't play a part
like they were very against it right and
if you listen to my word in the thing
about them they work hard in the
summertime that they want to be want to
get better each and every year and in
this day and age especially basketball
you need those tough guys you need those
guys that you know well don't mind
getting someone's face and I think
that's that's helped Boston throughout
the year he got it with Ben Simmons in
the night and I believe a pushover and I
think it's helped their grit in their
toughness
of their team always great to talk to
you Jared joy The Conference Finals my
friend appreciate the time can you
thought a minute thank you God it's
Jared Dudley the Phoenix Suns forward
joining me here on the Dan Patrick show
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]